[Musique]
alexis miranville ancien professeur
d'histoire géographie dans le secondaire
bon moi je suis un arrière petit fils
d'esclave 1 je ne suis ni fier ni
honteux parce que je n'y suis pour rien
des parents totalement il est très
vivant dans une case en paille pendant
que j'étais prof
j'étais je faisais partie aussi d'une
association qui s'appelait l'arca
association pour l'alphabétisation des
adultes
j'ai fait deux années d'enseignement à
la sakay à madagascar
et quand j'ai découvert cette société
coloniale
c'est là que je me suis mis à l'histoire
de la réunion
donc j'ai emmagasiné les résultats de
mes recherches et c'est après la
retraite que j'ai pu commencer à faire
mes publications portant sur l'histoire
locale et plus particulièrement sur
celle de saint paul est également sur le
quartier historique de villèle
[Musique]
j'ai été également co fondateur de
l'association des musées au fil de
villèle
c'est une association qui a son siège au
musée et qui travaille pour le
rayonnement du musée
mais j'ai également écrit les textes des
panneaux
l'exposition sur la grotte des premiers
français qui sont toujours visibles et
sur la vie quotidienne des esclaves de
madame desbassyns
rigoureux rigoureux parce que c'est
indispensable quand on veut faire de
l'histoire l'historia n'avance rien sans
preuve
il doit toujours porter un regard
critique sur les ressources qu'ils
utilisent
[Musique]
beaucoup de réunionnais connaissent
encore mal leur histoire les programmes
scolaires déjà chargé laisse peu de
place à un tel enseignement les
commémorations officielles et d'autres
date bien choisie pourrait être
également l'objet d'exposés de
conférences d'activités périscolaires
cela se fait déjà dans certains
établissements
mais cela pourrait être généralisé voire
amplifier